foreign
Island hey Elizabeth welcome to the show
hello thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help
well about five weeks ago my 16 month
old baby and I fled a domestic violence
situation and had to relocate to another
state and start over thankfully we're
safe now
but there's a whole financial situation
um going on obviously my finances are in
shambles and
right now what I am trying to do as I'm
beginning to work through the baby steps
is figure out where buying a car and
saving for a home falls into that
process as I have neither yes
wow how are you doing Elizabeth I mean
that's that is that's intense I mean
that's a that's a a traumatic thing that
you you've walked through
yes it has been very intense very
stressful and a lot of things I'm
working through you know as a human yes
do you have good support around you
I do have a couple of good friends and a
couple of family members good good good
because you're you know your your health
and your safety is
is priority
um so I'm thankful to hear that
absolutely where where are you staying
now
with a friend okay well good on you for
getting out of that situation absolutely
that's so difficult especially with a 16
month old baby
um you know I can't begin to imagine how
you're feeling right now but you know
you've got this whole New Horizon in
front of you and it's a whole clean new
start so you know yes there's a lot of
Hope a lot a lot of Hope do you have a
job Elizabeth are you making any money
no I'm not okay that's part of the issue
yeah
um that's okay that's okay uh do you see
that coming into play soon for you are
you applying for jobs did you have work
experience uh before
yes I do um have work experience what
I'm doing right now is I am currently
enrolled in a course that teaches you
how to take pictures and videos for food
bloggers so I'll be a professional
photographer from home and I graduate in
April so awesome probably in May is when
I'll start to be bringing in the money
yes is there anything that you could
start doing today in order to bring in
some extra income
if I could find something from home yes
because unfortunately the friend I live
with has a lot of diseases and illnesses
and she's extremely high risk so to have
to put my baby in daycare would be
chancing my friend's safety and actual
life you know if my baby comes back with
some kind of sickness or covet God
forbid so okay I'm kind of hanging tight
on state benefits and so I have my own
income how much is that
um the state is giving me 600 a month
cash assistance and then for food 389
okay
and can you tell us a little bit about
like your debt situation
um coming out of that relationship like
what's your obligation to the debt
um tell us about that
um well I walked into that relationship
with no debt except for about 4 000 in
medical bills okay
um and I walked out of it with seventeen
thousand dollars total debt so that's
eleven thousand dollars in credit cards
five thousand medical bills two thousand
and a program I'm paying off
um
a certification program I graduated from
two years ago so some of it's his but
unfortunately it's under my name
um
so I'm the one who has to pay it you
know I think right now the name of the
game is Just survival I think that you
have like Rachel said you've come out of
really out of a very traumatic situation
and you just need some time to get your
bearings under you and for you right now
that's you going to school it's you
um starting to have a stable income so
that you're able to move out of the
friend's house and I think that's thing
one is getting some income in whether
that's if there's anything you can do
from from home now I'd hate for you to
have to wait till April to start working
but yeah Elizabeth I would say too you
know we talked to so many people on the
show and there's so many side hustles
yeah via just your computer right that
the work from home stuff obviously is
everywhere but even if you can be a
virtual assistant for for 15 hours a
week you know you don't have to jump
into a lot but just to bring in some
level of income to save because your
next your next Big Goal yes is going to
be to find somewhere to live
um and and then the second is Staff
Transportation those two kind of have to
happen I would say together if you can
and the transportation could be a two
thousand dollar cost that's right it
doesn't have to be anything fancy and
even where you live finding low rent so
um look at this next step it can be it I
think it for me it would be easy
to say I'm starting a new life and
because you've been so in such an
uncomfortable insane situation to jump
into I just want to feel comfortable and
so I would say to resist Elizabeth just
those two big things your your car and
where you live that your car is not
going to be the car that you're going to
drive forever so it's not going to be
beautiful and wonderful and that's okay
for now
um and then also where you live you know
it may not be in the part of town that
is ideal for you or what whatever the
situation is but finding those expenses
to be as low as possible as you're
starting out I think will be a really
big blessing
okay so you guys would recommend that
before paying off any debt because I
know like the payments are honestly it's
very Hefty I the cash assistance coming
from the state isn't even enough to
cover that I mean if there's minimum
payments you can make I mean just
minimum if you're able to make minimum
payments you definitely want to do that
stay current on your on those on the
debt if you have it yeah but as far as
working a snowball or anything like that
I just don't think that you're in that
place right now I think right now like I
said you're just getting your bearings
you're working on getting your income up
and then so that you can eventually save
up enough to find another place whether
it be an apartment or something like
that yeah Elizabeth when we do a budget
with people we always say the first four
main categories to make sure covered are
food shelter utilities and
transportation and so I kind of want to
build those four walls of your new life
before you go and start saving up for
the emergency funds and the debt
snowball and all of that um and so I
think getting that stability under you I
think even just emotionally Elizabeth is
gonna is gonna give you a breath of like
fresh air to say okay I'm starting this
life and you're going to have a new
schedule you guys are going to be in a
new Rhythm you and your and your baby uh
and then that's when you're gonna be
able to say okay I'm in that stable
place and I'm ready to freaking attack
this debt and get it out of my life
forever and you will Elizabeth like I
can hear that in your voice you've
survived yes uh again one of one of the
worst situations ever and so this debt
is going to be nothing you're going to
be able to knock it out but I would I
would get that Foundation under you
first
okay that makes sense
oh thank you for calling Elizabeth I
really do I appreciate you reaching out
and and I have is there anything else
that Jade and I can walk you through do
you have any other questions
um I I don't think so I think that
answers my question okay wonderful well
thanks again for calling
so tough but she's such a Survivor I
mean look at her it's amazing I can't
even put my to put myself in that
position of taking a 16 month old baby
out of a violent home which is the right
thing to do absolutely going with no
place to live no car no money more you
know absolutely yep and you're going
into a friend's like she is just such a
she's just such a hero right now and I
want her to hear that and Elizabeth stay
on the line Austin's gonna pick up and
we're gonna give you uh Financial Peace
University for a year and every dollar
as well uh to start budgeting and and
take and and watch those videos because
that's gonna really reinforce even from
starting from that beginning Point okay
so what what am I doing how do I start
this and so Financial abuse university
really is one of the best things to walk
you through that as well so stay on the
line and Austin will pick up and we'll
give that to you and actually awesome
throw in a Total Money Makeover book as
well because that'll be a quick read
people read that in like two days it's a
quick read but again Elizabeth getting
that that that knowledge and getting a
community around you so I'm glad that
you have that but even here at Ramsey
we're like we consider ourselves
People's Community too so yes so having
books and podcasts and and all of that
and find a good church home if you're
not connected somewhere I don't care
what you believe church is great for
everybody yes get around some Community
strong women out here Rachel for sure oh
yeah Jade I mean it's a lot of Life
happening and all of you caller all of
you listeners out there
um everyone's in a different situation
but different struggles different points
of celebration in life but money is
always seems to be a thread yes that
runs right through people's lives so
that is why we are here